tell you that our program is slightly
altered for what appears in front of the
program unfortunately professor Deborah
machine design with us today so we only
have three presentations rather than
four and we're going to try to end this
session at four o'clock rather than 415
to allow for a half hour between this
panel next one I know many people here
have come from far away I flew in from
California this morning and so rest are
going to getting full after every panel
so try to four o'clock in three
wonderful presentations in this panel on
gender and generational relations and
the first is because they're similar
matters to me from the University of
random dude in France and it is entitled
burger gender tension between Islam and
France and his wrong of friends and she
was going to move over chair to the
podium and back unless she has some
special presentation
you can stick
between Milton of France and Muslim
friends I've been growing tips that hate
due to the piety of immigration policies
in front flattening world but also
because of the comic relief that are
restrained number of immigrants and
political refugees would failure a
better integration of DB Norton freshman
enemy we became an indicator of animals
religious catalyzation after differently
according to the gender & 3 generations
ladies I will result represent a solid
game books about transmission and a
proposed haha
but even a proposal made the distracting
neurological revolutionary movement that
is the authentic information from people
in France tuition or friends firstly the
religious immigration deficiency of
categorization of our business as an
increase or suffered a lot workers and
accidentally that accompanied the
analysis of the religious ray majority
of blatant England for example the work
of joining party on catholicism of
public knowledge little immigration
started to be studied in france
especially in relation with Islam each
mama is a categorical for political
analysis that is Audrey Muslims it
adopted economics without any distance
between the eighties and nineties
according to Nancy
Islam become demoted the motives of her
distinguish the new need or the
environment from the former one former
migrants have been here email associated
with European and George polish we would
have been able to integrate into the
political process while there are no way
nowadays consider to be mostly covered
mid manuals and from the French
operation so there are three categories
this distinction is also related with
Armitage organization of European
migration policies I mean the opposition
between Europeans and no you feel me
what's mine the idea of evolution is in
infancy what are the categories of music
that resurrection integrates on between
pages and denying tease this is the
question the production of several
trials of newsmen of movements and the
gradual dissociation from migration
categories in yet modern workers are the
main focus on an axe these Muslims are
tolerated because there are expected to
return to that hungry or the 20
883 strikes in regardlessly are
accompanied by religion slaves in
particular related to work worship which
will be the first moment to raise but we
later on gradually vinglish information
with the Declaration of working
condition of working conditions degree
of unemployment rates the closure of
manufacturers in the nineties the
recession in the focus on islam by
separate more more immigration and this
one a new category in Earth's emeritus
adoni to what is now considered to be
the liberal friends friend young women
with my god background especially
islamist verbal with heart starts with
achievable the shift from those we don't
know whether they will sell or not to
French men and women with specifically
with specific regions their assignment
for position the resistor external to
the national series be attributed to the
cafeteria and exercise religious
preacher cartel as a matter of fact in
the nineties the metal music culture
replace the AIDS focus on the future of
origin while under the label of original
culture prayer rooms in the factories
had beaten raped with idea that migrant
workers could only
turn to their country music culture will
be assigned to the freshman and minion
with background and they re appropriated
it also treated as a problem of Public
Order primary related French men and
women with background these interim of
France people's first effort of origin
of excitation or of suspicions the issue
of Islam in Europe is today a political
beauties the presence of Muslims is
ineligible and without backtracking the
question in the change for all Muslim
and non-muslim non-music is whether even
in Newark can be can become even from
Europe in connection with prostrated is
that the idea of a rupture with the
phone services of visibility of needed
workers because many can eat noodles go
to Morsi to pray but create alternative
spaces around educational and cultural
activities to equate that faith with
their social life as federal rolled in
describe your movement of his own
friends too even from friends means
means recognizing that most of these
young Muslims were burned French and
educate in fact reports the underlying
design promised face reduce always under
categories of publication and a grammar
of belonging that is understood since is
information as programmatic finally the
gradual concentration of research on the
answers with migrant backgrounds mostly
focus on girls wearing the odds are in
the Palisades and in the public schools
in particular and it's move-in is mostly
looking at its articulation with bridges
of citizenship however the political
regime and legitimacy of the
identification of citizenship as a
problem that must lead to a legislative
resource is ignoring scientific analysis
average annual growth in a 25 each way
to 800
what is that the art about that the two
thousand 40 which band the heads of in
public school republic of fact divided
divided the family's movement in France
neatly machines were favorable to the
low and Catholic sexism and hamster
versus representative of French majority
families such as Christine defeat within
the families collected for equality that
also includes young music winner with
backgrounds which refer to Islam as a
vital for the claim of individual rights
Moroccan music families that lambda beta
is the founder of a current president of
international growth group for study and
reflection on women in Islam z axis and
it illustrates the transmission
dimension of this dynamics this music
palace grows included museum from Europe
North America North African countries
and from the windows is it illustrated
with illustrated the opportunity
provided by identification with infant
formula to develop
transnational dynamics international
congress and somalia organized by his
lip families like the facts alone at up
to two thousand five congrats it up
straight to the legitimacy of sharing
experience and music families discourses
we're beyond the context of migration
the division are not so much on your
food opposition between my battery
contacts and countries where these
amines the majority the difference is in
the GFE are related to the consideration
of the same sacred religious types and
the relation to the school considering
the national values of Islam that I have
sought represented within the example
about news and families how can we still
cited today that the more Islam is
becoming French nationalized and
affiliated to the national context the
more it seems overtaken by an issue
these are being investigated in local
contacts for example for example the
work of concern yourself in Alice in
Messiah we do strangers this constant
interaction between the unique magnets
for miles and the essence of immigrants
black Porsche this is involved is
because already come to the
on constant terms we know that in France
the ever increasing number of uses
different people mainly or legal English
fairly ramification marriage there are
the arrival skilled workers and asylum
seekers and living in vegetables this
would maintain a stable population creed
of beauty over 1600 for miles without
diva originating mail from Asia and
North and Central Africa actually which
are the music figures that are forgotten
in this shape from New Zealand friends
to musics from friends my answer is that
looking at my mothers and their children
could help us to identify them for what
a reciprocal it is important to
understand Islam about modern mothers
and their children I have an exact
identification
and positioning of social actors in fans
who did not seem irrelevant as am using
actors neither impact policy Norwich
French society with innocent women mr.
miles I've been reduced to some cinder
really not least interesting something
like a cultural tradition basket with a
black cat retraction garbage and they
they this will seem to me they also
dangerous per day is Eliza daughter
furthermore some fear is a very
boundaries especially in the natural
world which is one of the few to take
into account the position of parental
transmission present a passive process
of evaporation of in- by the children
deficient oh road has the primary
persons in charge of newborn babies
mothers contributes within a
relationship of body care emotional and
intellectual development of the human
beings to human eyes and realize that
their children research that were
limited to the study production and
reproduction of ethnicity from the
perspective of who wins position of
neglected the active role children in
precise in the process of transition
they forgot them if the children can
also be span from the perspective of an
effective displays produce the
intercourse of interactions that are
enough restore this
when the process of transmission
we can ask now how can young children
contribute to modify the parent
orientation while presenting themselves
as new for example this is the meaning
of the crime under follows that I heard
from young boards I brought to cinema
during school vacation and it is also
the set for young girls I staff rope
around the neck and covering the
hairline to pretend to be wearing a
staff in early afternoon during the
which is an educator from of ladybug and
myself accompanied to a dozen son the
student from prior primary school to see
a movie or little bit the Paris Metro
Sri money notice one reads of contact
lenses this already happened before it
is in this parents also some 100 the
teacher then accompanied Suleiman to the
pharmacy and suggested that I to visit
to the church with a result aside the
place we work with the other student
answering the featured suggestions I am
built thinking of involved in the
parents for a while we are not very
open-minded there is nothing wrong in
visiting a church you're looking at DTU
the same way as with most being an
addict I made
proposal to the room that intellectual
which can be visited at a museum and a
few solely as a place of worship the
answer is over- our parents do not want
us to do that we are all right go inside
a Christian Church they shot laughing
Elizabeth Rigby these students
considered invitational and drink the
church and after ovulation the first
reaction life is involved in a normal
reference the Taipans make objectify
women of the church this also shows that
light in the internals a universal
Venice in which Christianity places of
worship conceptual poor represent a
cultural difference that made them that
may make them until including sitting to
say even rabbit impossible or enforce a
physical business that they want to
click when the announcer is just outside
the church real i'm here on the seam all
performance while the French educator is
sweetening to came to it under the
pretext of opening the grounds these
children
themselves an unknown wooden bodies but
also for specific goals such as clothing
or language they are available in the
social space whoever these tools were
not necessarily intended reviews in that
way when using kids to perform am using
a museum idents they don't always behave
as children mood for instance pain or
not the evil in which they cheat on
their feet the way their parents you can
either send teachers would or undies
that this is what we found in
interaction mention Europe in front of
the church in Paris and in in the forum
discussion with a parrot design books
and does that some of them are likely to
receive
you can see colors like these little
books and told me that some of them are
likely to receive a way of reminding
them what would be the right way to act
I have mutant children and you suggest
that they should do for their group of
gloating the Museum of friends but they
may also use such tools bypass in the
sexual and religious complete messages
die ability whether intentional or
unconscious base was more day markets
such as the views of invocation you are
of before the time or they are made of
clear per my request for children to
play when they are seven years old this
setting community leader to focus on
your files reducing children to private
residence or endorse this neglected of
children in with your immigration
situation the astonishment of models
which are narrated Edison's the easel of
the charges of the same manages and that
of many parents learned that their
daughter in a later age means take away
many of them feel that they means
something education and the position
would be serving the freshest are many
parents
their children regardless of age are not
inside to enslave the little Mother's
know that they are traditions with their
daughters on issues of modesty include
maintaining this version does allow link
for future that may produce section
reporting news news the young women of
North Africa David's manager modest
regulation to specific roles and
generation these modest is built under
de vis day in Normandy demographers
whoever defects of imputation modesty
that sometimes ends up the surprising
the mothers themselves and some artists
are instructed by the reaction they
considered excessive share of their
promoters robber they cannot put
themselves with the same things money is
to focus on the element Mississippi in
the parental formation of both sides
hard sermons are replicated in English
by this young children develop the
margins of member of the orig generation
stations and generations indeed trying
to focus on the privatization of Islam
many researchers are pointed up to the
lack of religious reasons or that is it
in religious coordination for freshman
and French women with brown backgrounds
but it takes more interesting
see how children are positioned against
notable configuration of transition in
other cases the settings can write a
heater to focus on your parents reducing
children to pass residents nor indoors
is neglect of childhood migration
station or to take little in the young
women with a director scholars interim
we say that a hard cut at cattle
measurement transmission feeding a
system of original transmission because
they're only in the context a woman's
circles needs knowledge
may your presentations our second
speaker is
who is the joint director at southern
for South Asian Studies authorities and
strategies the internal first generation
so the Turkish elements Thank special
use one inviting me but I think I had
very hard talks to speak at the last
speaker or a session afterward sorry
afternoon New York your old pirate I'm
completely jet lag it's time to go back
to me up to my warm milk after all these
excellent presentation and I hope that
we won't sleep doing how is coming yes I
would try to give some some information
on the Turkish my twins living in France
even the title the term of Turks in
France is a problematic tunnel we know
that approximately there are 200,000
approximately turkish citizens living in
friends and the we estimate that there
are 200,000 french citizens but turkish
background living but it's difficult to
calculate because we don't have the
professionals we don't have statistics
they can be doubled against those new g
or single trenches and Jethro typical to
document that we consider that we have
approximately 400,000 people related to
Turkey one way or another related turkey
because they are not all ethnic Turks
there is a huge my
within the minority willingly people
coming from Turkey which is the Kurdish
minority of course and all these 400,000
people are Muslims we do not include in
this in the way of calculating and the
identifying Turks and people already
from Turkey we are not including all the
non-muslims originating from Turkey but
living in French are really important
100,000 French armies are coming from
other non Muslim population also see
reacts chaldean etc so we are talking
about the Muslims Muslims not live Go Go
service taste or practice belonging to
Islam and even for dads would have some
problems because approximately twenty
percent twenty to thirty percent of this
Turkish minority in France belong three
ala be religion so to put this this
group within the group of Muslims is
problematic because they they have a
different discourse liberal claims etc
as you see that the existing vehicles up
are difficult to story history of people
originally from Turkey in front a very
well-known up to nineteen sixty-four
ready bilateral agreement between
President turkey like all other
migration chase normal migration coming
in France's were
after 1974 of the BL the agreement they
could bring their wives and children and
it became a real minority in in France
half of this population we think are
born in France this is the problem of
the generation I'm listening to you
since this morning are going much and
thank you very much for all these
communications but we are I have
impressions we are using this term of
second-generation as it was something
very nation and no we know all that is
terminal the concept of second
generation is a very very problematic
concept what we call secondary is it
enough to be born in France or to be
educated in France all maybe it must be
people born in France from parents born
in France which one both pregnant or one
of his controller etc we have many many
problems with external second generation
and I think that there is the Turkish
specificity in Turkish specificity
people or JD from Turkey
geography the Turkish specificity since
1980s many studies on the line this
specificity I think too much there is no
one single Turkish group which is
completely different from the other one
is in in France for in Western Europe in
general but in this case of generation
case I think there is a specificity and
abstraction to explain animal acts on
some characteristic wirelessly maybe
explanation for example it is a length
language after 1960s there is no
migration substantial migration from
Turkey towards Western Europe before
1960s so like it is also a group without
French culture it's very very good I
mean all these migration in friends we
are separating people from X colonies
who knows french language this french-
but who has a difficult relationship
between friends for knives oh my it's a
trap so there is no this history between
France entropy this proximity of hate
and love between aronson to get even
there is a ideological history between
friends and chalky b-body Turkish
revolution had part open spaces from the
French Revolution and French idea of
nation state and this is maybe also one
of the rhythms of the specificity
because the Turkish what we were
nation-state exclusivist identity is
very similar to french exclusivist
identity the same rule
of constructing the ed building Nation
this human process our own or in Turkey
and in France that's why they needed
Turkish identity and French items they
are rivals congruence between Turkish
and very difficult to construct a
discourse of double belonging to the
French pneus and to be to the Turkish
pneus and he went for the religion I
mean we were talking with simota about
this his son of from France Islam off
press is done in French Islam French's
values this is very very well-known
deterritorialization of a religion of
nation-states each nation state quantum
territorial animation like the religion
a little something it is like not
impressed and it is bible in Turkey also
so this the materialization of the
religion Turkish time of Islam in the
French dialogue Islam the process are
very similar but there is a
comprehensive DVDs to protest rock maybe
aswad also erase this this specificity
di yahoo the transformation from an
empire very strong Empire to the
nation-state less strong nations name or
similar in press Enter key proud of
being an empire and donate in the world
but to be less strong today but in the
nation state national capital initiative
or similar so you see that there is this
specificity of identity building it's
been specially for multiple and identity
in Turkish in Turkish case i will
discuss i will try to discuss this
concept of second generation that I
think what try to explain myself I think
that we are indicators in what I call in
some articles when I got a strategy of
first generation I don't think that
there is a second or third generation of
Turks in France I started to think about
that along this strategy of perverting
first generation in 2002 in 2002 they
asked me if I'm looking at Southern
University I teach in two different
departments international relations
institute and in turkish state park and
this Turkish Studies department we have
many many courses on Turkish language to
personalization Turkish history
sociology etc etc and in 2002 the French
history of national education asked me
to participate in the jury's of a
Columbia English did you know the final
exam I school for Turkish Kurdish
language introduced a garnish for pupils
students I students can say to Turkish
language and history as one of their
courses and then they had a written exam
and then they pass the oral exam
tomorrow it's a man with the Stars in
Turkish and I have to evaluate a degree
of turkey turkish language
Turkish culture and still get the job as
so I started let between 2002 and 2005
two or three years I will truly of me
Claire so I had the chance to see
approximately 800 French young men and
young women 18 19 years old with Turkish
background so most of all maybe all our
boring friends and for some of them if
parents are born in France at the end of
the conversation during your life giving
text reading in Turkish Delight some
personal text comprehension little extra
I started to ask the first and main
question when Turkish guy needs another
Turkish guy in question we're early from
it we asked which I need and it was well
first question they vary from before you
will be made it's really the micro
belonging in Turkish society is very
very polluting and I was told to myself
that I will make some cities I will see
in from which region of friends they are
coming all those Paris at the trap
message on the first and second and
third and detailed in the trap k all the
same answer the village or city from
church startling statistic so I was
waiting me the first one will tell me
I'm comparison from I don't know one
from south loop on would know and I was
estimate come on when did you come to
France Rihanna
honey i'm ordering my parents walk
around but still still the second third
generation were giving this place is
microblogging placed as there some
people some young people as if i am
living enticing don't use for me i say
you came time for dinner by my address
that anger notes at straws would be
Paris red but I live in KY c never mean
it I similarly in in a very very broken
church what is that what is that what is
this you know this link to the
geographical origin to the parents and
even rampant and then I try to develop
this I hope to study your first
generation I think that this strategy
exists and this strategy uses three
types of agent of transmission of
identity to pertain to keep always the
first generation there in practice that
the generations born in France educated
in France socialized in France feel feel
the same things towards turkey than the
parents and the grammar it's available
Simmons it's at zero the first agent of
transmission of identity national
identity Turkish identity or even
traditionally oh it is
different just taking traditionally
dishes language and for crystallization
teachers there are two types of Turkish
education in the French system we have I
think they are nine of all friends
Turkish my wish servants of the French
educational system only 94 not 0
children you salute but ninety percent
maybe ninety five percent of the
education of the Turkish language and
Turkish the possession history are made
by what we call elko this morning
somebody talk about alko alko is
insanely wound around equal division the
education of culture and language from
the originated country and they are sad
by the Turkish government they are paid
by interview terminal and they give they
make some sunglasses in the French
public schools but not during these
clothes Wednesday is afternoon 00 or
weekends and should be French season
young men and young girls are gay are
following these courses in the virtual
but given by traditional Turkish teacher
so just put one side is language courses
but just to understand that in all
service but the Turkish language in
France everybody else of all parents all
terms and so that they want to have
teachers from Turkey this is a to be
from Turkey to be
to speak the real Turkish at the fact
they don't have they don't work even the
daily own children educated children
become a teacher or or the Turkish
language I mean it's a brother-brother
Pelini Department of Turkish studies we
have this you know the source we can
educate the teachers for tourists and
establish that is they do not want they
want to be related linked directly to
the original to the opt-out the Turkish
pneus varieties teaches so the first
agent of transmission and then language
and language yes especially language and
only mr. that especially the language we
know that in the minority situation what
we call identity has 2x language and
religion we know that it is difficult to
transmit in minority language in the
majority situation and the religion
becomes in the minority presentation the
main identification able to be an
incident to be a national identity
national epidemic so the second agent of
transmission of identity of services our
Imams we made a study in 2002 and 2003
on the moms with color to fly from
progressive political scientist excuse
me and we try to understand what who are
these amounts working in France or as in
Charlie Turkish girls and so this study
as republished in 2004 on amongst in
then in France and I don't say that
another say that approximately sixty
percent of Imams Turkish moms working in
the French most Turkish French must are
sad by two Turkish government between
nineteen sixty-four and 1983 so during
20 years the Turkish government were
very far from the from these migrants
settled in France and Germany in the
balance countries during this 20 years
Brotherhood associations political Islam
especially Meleager the national vision
open some moss in France and in Germany
the center was and is always karate
tournament in journey and but even those
people imported from Turkey some Imams
early in germany and france in the
direction field in military and in
belgium to work in the turkish masts
after 1983 when the Turkish government
started to Sandy's Imams by a dt the
election zombie Religious Affairs the
Union Turkish Muslim Union it's the name
of the institution of Yogi's he will
have to that association which are not
in the network of the official Turkish
states were they continue to use to
outwork Imams coming freshly from turn
not content when we when we
another this study in 2002 I wasn't
touch with approximately 80 Imams in the
Turkish waters no one single among women
friends for more than two years all
amounts were coming freshly from church
which is very interesting for us because
after 2007 recently we suffered in
France a real debate as you know trendy
moms the french models knowing the
French language the French tradition the
French Way of life the French name of
the Republican Imams and some initiative
be taken for training involved in planet
especially as you know maybe he took the
Institute of Paris started a program of
training evolved very funny to see that
people are going to the Catholic
attitude to be involved and then
complain in the French mosques in
stressful we start in 2008 must if a
program of master of Islam ology to
train some Muslim what intellectual nuts
Imams what intellectuals who will be the
internal Peter between the French
society and the Muslim connect so to see
if there was an attempt and reception
for all these training programs we made
the survey in 2009 just lust I was
injured bald goatee Turkish muscles I
went to all these Turkish matter i
explained the cage we are trying to
build training program for emails what
do you think maybe you will you will
hire one of these emails or your months
it's a treasure approximately ninety
four
the answers for heather was no of course
imams must come from jerk even our Imams
people who are from the Turkish
community from their community having
it's raining here in France are not
considered as a palliative original kept
capital kinetic capable to make to be
involved in the Turkish month so still
today a specificity of the Turkish the
lady in his advocate for the road no not
really which are accepting these
immigrants his specificity of the trans
community community is still importing
Imams from frontally in that sense it's
very difficult for the Turkish community
in France to be included in this
discourse of territorial edition of
Islam the French is not because among
the main you know religious a minister
we here in front are coming yesterday
contact and for that for that reason
also it is very huge mistake to consider
all these amounts more than what they
are doing as social agents you know to
be nice gap between the society and
minority as a clinical day too much
speak French they are most Texans was
coming to us for all these amounts on
who have an interview with you could you
please give me the address with your
loss well no one no one completely lost
one year two years three years in France
without French
language in a small community so in
battle in these conditions it is very
difficult to see the Turkish community
in this discourse of constructing a
French is not territorial I fleshlight
management branch Islam so the second
agent of transmission of identity the
Turkish this to be done in direct link
with Turkey and Turkish Islam and third
one this is related but you were saying
about the end agree i think that the the
the main thing important for imported
from Turkey to France they are young men
and young women sadistically church
people from Turkey imprints are not very
interesting the non Turks so mixed
marriages are existed are absent just
put on all religious out are mixed in a
very awesome son but its cultural tricks
Mary marriages between Turks and umbrage
yes we know that but again statistically
Turks are not very terse in France
either all young men and young women
rights are important from Turkey it is
an undulating yes Laura it's a micro and
dependent it is not based on the nation
for me it is not based on only on you
in our region might book below so today
approximately I think in figure was
ninety-four percent of another week on
that study 2004 from mcallen Stefan
todavia all children born in France so
we can consider them now Concepcion at
second generation to generation have at
least one of two parents coming Freddie
hunter and in majority models so the
transmission of the identity of dilution
II Turkish this is through all these
mothers having freshly fresh flow to
France for the language for the religion
traditions behavior vision way of saying
the world how to speak out to eat only
culture are given for these mothers
curry just week ago from turn in under
these conditions to consider this
population these kids born in france as
a second-generation i think since they
say conceptual aaron addiction admission
in addition deep globalization me that
it is very easy to make to have the
circulation of migration physically to
go to Turkey combative to one of ours it
is very easy to have some products from
Turkey some from who Oh produce them in
Europe of the informations for a Turkish
house in television is the aquarium
always reach over 3000 as soon they are
they are always under the source of
political on Turkey it helps to keep
this is identity as it but it is still a
strategy I will finish follow this
strategy exists to kill the identity of
the first generation and in reality we
know that this identity is dynamic we
know that the discourse of being turn
from Turkey is a strong discourse among
these young people but still in this
dynamic identity there is a mix of being
French and be Turkish it is greater se20
before 2000 among our students Turkish
background since we started to you the
discourse of multiple identity with our
friend challengers at the same level etc
when the Turkish when turkey became the
official candidate to the European Union
the discourse in France had been
radicalized against Turkey not because
turkey wasn't in Europe but Turks were
Europeans and by reaction after 2000 we
started the new an exclusivist identity
this caused from terms of work you're
only Turks we are not French but in
reality of course they say is in French
I mean you see we can say that this mix
of the construction the building of the
new identity and for new minority in
is an ongoing process and testing
process strategy exists but i think and
hope it is condemned to pay thank you
very much for you we have a lot of
empirical material also theoretical
insights on discussion and I'd like to
invite anyone the audience would like to
make a comment or ask a question
when you do speak if you please
introduce yourself and say where you're
from it microphone to speak
Muhammad never American University I
want to raise an ethical question the
same question I raced on Muslim
Brotherhood in America I want to raise
it regarding the behavior of the of the
French nationals and they use the same
approach looking at Nationals of
citizens with foreign attachment
applying this idea to France so from
what I learned from the presentations of
all de France allows imported Imams made
by foreign governments tolerates the
interference of foreign governments in
elections in my ority communities in
France and they allow turkish foreign
teachers to come and teach another
French culture to the public students in
France and then questioned the freshness
of of their own senses I think if this
is something wrong you brought it on
themselves and you have to just
acknowledge that you are dealing with
with with a with a situation where you
have French citizens in a in a global
age friends is actually benefiting by
making those minority communities
self-reliant because if I if they cannot
support themselves for those basic needs
the French government will have to pay
for
and yet they allow awkward governments
to pay for them and then you go after
your own citizens and tell them how
French are you I think there is an
ethical question to be asked stemming
from the situation I appreciate just
included m27 you are right but I will be
very cynical on simply creation of CFC
and the French Council of Muslim code
from French government all Frenchmen all
these important amounts pay by these
foreign countries were very good because
one of course they were paid by the
parental caliper background but second
they were controlled by the foreign
countries all these are in consumer
culturally the East code of these Imams
and when there is a problem with all
these in with the discount they can have
positive agreement between friends and
this this country's rural area and
entered after the creation of serious
disease here I do France became a pretty
building of french french kissin and
maybe not today friends is capable to
control this all his phone amount that's
what we see today all these training
health clinical programs for polygons
months without these agreements between
France and other countries for friends
it was seen as a danger clearly a danger
so to have some free amounts they
prepare to have amongst control my blood
over Jerry abide by Turkey and pay by a
vital key so it is a humanistic for
multicultural approaches which are
allowing the arrival of these evils
really cynical
and secretary Franco varies but after
the creation of the six and let's write
because they control Islam and they say
to his amount to practical this yep see
our video role about escapes here real
elected consul of Turkey editor the
Muslim cold in France on suitcases the
first was the heads currency it became
the divorce of the government to explain
the field what was why it was for
bethesda the second well sue fresh
journalists have been kidnapped in Iraq
they went to Iraq to explain that French
wasn't the country again from that they
absolutely these two journals that's all
that's all it is a real artificial
artificial in tradition on started by
friends in this notation to control to
territorial a spirit Turkish way of
thinking on that point of view turkey is
a deity
the face directory administration which
became an example well I'm wondering if
the Turkish Kurds identified well I am
sorry Turkish pneus Turkish this has
three different definitions the first
definition of Turkish this is a legal
one article 66 of the Turkish
composition is saying that people who
are linked to the purpose republic by
the way from TV series enjoyed our talk
starts on that point whole point of view
curves legally archers and because there
is go to this town recognized what they
are come to test your turban says this
but they can help of course the ethnic I
am the second identification of the
Turkish news is good news Muslim Turkish
speaker but Muslim not only Muslim but
multiple Muslims who need an appt etc
even for otherwise there are some some
problem and the third hit third
definition is it raishin one all the
troops from Central Asia till the ball
comes with Turkish nation as a private
I'm sure are more and more in
identifying themselves as terms and
claiming even a core business to reason
to that first of all curve participate
in Turkish migration up to 1960s to the
person Europe and there they found a
more liberal environment to express
their again
it was quite impossible in Turkey was
quite impossible to one until the end of
nineteen nineties it was impossible to
people the world of pronouncing injury
and secondly today the traditionals
became one of the main problems debate
in Turkey and is free to express it and
even if there are many many problems so
13 Western Europe are sometimes with
throws but awfully they consider a real
identical and ethical legal group
Chester is a problem some curves because
of this relations policies in Jersey are
not foolish students so they had there
is a linguistic problem but other curves
are other speakers and so they consider
a special and more is not a majority but
most of them are LEDs there are some
other bees in Kurdish
we have other questions
but I live in France first of all thank
you very much for your purchase commands
for the Turkish in completions following
this lead and I will I met some parents
and thanks to children I was able to
fuse my parents thanks to achieve
because indeed after a third third rows
in front scallops where roads able to
speak in French I was impressed by the
ability of parents to transmit a
broadness of origin so I think it's also
important to emphasize this because many
families for example North African
families there is no progress of origin
and we understand it very well because
colonization war between France and i'm
gerry goffin a child
it's not necessarily a source of protein
s very lousy some Turkish companies I
was impressed by the fact that some
father allowed to talk about Mustafa
Kemal in able to talk about the past of
Turkey and that's why for example a
burger in one family was pleased to meet
with you not because it was twisted
winning dragon pictures he was so
pleased to speak about Turkey a big
poster of mr. hockey vibe it living room
and cause permanent link with turkey
from the television because it's not a
tear for am transferring its Turkish
television i redesigned your furnace is
is important terms perhaps it's
something positive right away it's not
normative front something that I have
but Romero solid wire this ability to
transmit progress of origin my question
for you is about don't you think that
the stronger belonging with regard with
respect to Turkey is inter distribution
is also questioned and challenged or
France what extent does is to what
extent is from able to run you and
minority groups and their belongings in
strong's is involved in
it is a huge channel I do not think that
it's a positive thing it's approximately
eight years of great watching rate that
Turkish education again to the old in
Turkish generation the Turks must be
proud to return center which
nationalisms it right but it's created
exclusively side and also it's very
difficult to conceal himself itself at
the same time turf and something else as
it is very difficult to convey the
Frenchman something something else i
think that the multiple identity is very
difficult in the bridge trainer the
French context for drugs specifically
it's a double challenge for turkey
turkish an Indian and the French and
until well it's a real challenge to
change it happen for violence the
inference but also in Turkey to be able
to build this this multiple identity
shall not the boom the famous our
million singer friends were saying i
feel myself hundred percent French and
hundred percent Armenian from French
people and for Turkish people few things
up a lot dozen something and one
opponent there is no percentage of the
identity so I think it is a challenge
but I don't think that it's so my name
is crier
in Connecticut other person and I'm
fascinated appearance Casper and I'm
wondering to what extent intuitively or
by direct evidence but your description
of the Turkish community in France also
applies to Germany Italy the
Scandinavian countries Denmark Belgium
is it he replied phenomena well it is a
specific tool to French context I have
to confess injury it's a little bit
little bit different because the markets
the marriage part of this is broader
intro me tho 3 1 200 hot in these people
people coming from Turkey in Germany
their heart in me varies between Germans
second third generation and toast coming
from from Turkey but less than in
implants it is exactly the case in
Belgium and in the Netherlands it is not
the cases with in Sweden and Scandinavia
notice where there are some editing
specificities schematically there are
many church and non-muslim people coming
controversial serious I'll dance as a
result we can talk about the crush
specificity second / specificity is the
approach of exclusive is going to knock
the casing for greater works for example
it will become the case now nowadays
during just for two or three years in
rebels they are questioning their model
of multicultural belonging
but in fact art show
also second generation but still well
more than half yeah may told you about
you know but that's what it is the same
picture also the relation between and
end time with turkey and identifying
such as well as relations as carbonated
so people who feel more dutch to
masturbation people feel that they are
being Muslim is more important to them
that they are strongly religious also
feel that's Dutch for Turkish or
Moroccan so yeah we do see that that
it's sort of in some way isn't it
thank you I'm going to wrap him up we
went up after four o'clock because there
are so many things that people wanted to
talk about which is great we're going to
reconvene at four-thirty for the final
panel in the afternoon so it's coffee
was right